[Music]
[Applause]
Nicaragua is building a massive canal de
will split the country in two and uproot
thousands of people the chinese led firm
is running the project the government
hopes the canal will bring tens of
thousands of jobs and help lift
Nicaragua out of poverty but anti canal
activists accused the government of
selling out and they're getting
organized we traveled with activist
dennis castillo de Brito the coastal
town with the canal will meet the
pacific ocean the canal esta parte like
a pencil cooper etapa taking all this
bitch called banana Catalunya it's
beautiful
invisible sea mechanically got this
Acosta a grande que get the boys hit
though the mine eclectic often the
proposed canal would cross the
freshwater lake nicaragua and stretch
more than 170 miles to the caribbean
coast displacing more than a hundred
thousand people it would be wider deeper
than more than three times longer than
the Panama Canal the President Daniel
Ortega squirming has given the Chinese
led firm HK nd the rights to build the
canal without consulting the public
nicaragua's parliament approved the deal
in just a few days granting HK ND a 100
year tax-free concession that includes
the right to expropriate lands at will
in late December 2014 hundreds of
farmers protested around the country
police responded with violent crackdowns
look II kidding I said is enrolling at
my other country I papi I am a b20 Korea
Nicaragua Oh Tov your tiger is one of
the protest leaders targeted by
authorities la amenaza until cantante
Manasa de muerte a apart a two-way
Otilia that Anil manera legal we shall
buy him integral PLO metric - laronette
- ah so it may may may room cool
attaching in oh ho this protest don't
show any sign of going away you think
things are going to become more violent
around the country el campesino
Nicaraguan say a know why entry r su
propiedad de lo que queremos a victory
you may order a momento de sangre
Nicaragua it for a second also traveling
tomorrow we are categorical no se siente
Oliver - no para el I said or youth or
ago that night Octavio called a meeting
of anti Canal activists to prepare for
their next protest
which I know
[Music]
[Applause]
despite growing resistance in the canals
path the government insists the majority
of nicaragua's six million people favor
of the project so we're about 150
kilometers north of the capital Managua
this is a very poor area so we wanted to
find out how people feel will some of
the politicians are talking about them
up here merchant is on dock where the
del the canal 301 which I keep losing
him to camellia the table I think much
like a lot but around Lake Nicaragua the
project is anything but welcome when a
Chinese census team showed up in the
hamlet of cruz Verde in September 2014
farmers greeted them with machetes
[Music]
it's in the grass Aniki no yeah keno the
interim I keep telling me a land that I
get attack happened close to that
the caramel apple Azalea Emmanuel
Levinas
log was we important to a two-year
investigation by Nicaragua's leading
environmental group concluded the canal
poses an extraordinary threat to Lake
Nicaragua it further one that there will
not be enough water to maintain the
canal 25 years from now today the
Nicaraguan government has not issued an
environmental impact report of its own
[Music]
face not just from the environmental
consequences the canal clearly is going
to have on our main water resources on 4
s Monica Lopez Beltre Donna was a lawyer
who was fighting against the canal in
court she says there are 40
constitutional violations in the Chinese
concession but it's not just the
interest on e canal it's a dry canal
it's a pipeline it's to the water ports
it's an airport it's free trade zones so
the list keeps growing the direct
payment maker I was getting out of this
it's 100 million dollars for our 116
years concession 100 million dollars is
the amount of money that comes into our
economy every two months are migrating
people in Spain in aus in Costa Rica
they send in two months what the canal
concession is paying for 116 years so in
which head that it's a good deal
telemarket Ella vera is the government
spokesman for the canal project the
Chinese concession is paying the
government just ten million dollars a
year to operate the canal this is small
change
I've heard that remittances sent from
Nicaraguans living abroad are actually
more than this amount how is this
benefiting the people like Antioch ahe
NAWAPA Guerra Nicaragua sweet pequeña
effective pero parte ESO by pasando a
hola por ciento parano de la inversión a
patrimony Nacional para Hanner AR un
presupuesto más Alto unproductive in
turn o más Alto una condición economic a
sushi are para lo Nicaragua say mu
superior environmental activists here
say that this prize
will destroy the largest source of fresh
water lake nicaragua in Central America
to say nothing of all the tens of
thousands of people who will be
displaced by the canal project what do
you say to them
poor Nicaragua ilaria por la cual baaaa
transit a los barkos es menos de Loup no
por ciento de la superficie del Lago
pero de marte ESO se reforest are las
cuentas no solamente las cuevas de la
Senora Rio's llaman Nihar diferente las
cuentas yellow graphic 'as poor tanto
dimos el balon say Vasser positivo a un
impacto mental si lo aye yo soy de
janeiro al impacto meet our sin embargo
al balance a total s+ el ambiente ba ser
el gran cuñado quien a - ello grandes /
dolores lo que quieran que Nicaragua say
mantenga in lapa brezza
pero quiero la paz el per se les royal
palm one second outing in the absence of
transparency in with the stakes so high
it's difficult to say who will win in t
canal activists - refusing to back down
contra del Progreso no estoy en contra
Delhi who tisha ok let's start on the
tienda de Puebla de esta protesta no
monetary monetary endow okay against a
lucha no Totino's token Marie
[Music]
you